abdul mustafa seti is trying to counter
anti-vaccination messages being spread
on social media
he's clipping up videos of one of the
world's leading islamic scholars urging
people to ignore the fake news
and trust the science sheikh muhammad
spoke exclusively to sky news
believing in medical process is one of
the basic teachings of
islam
islam the teachings of quran
and the teachings of holy prophet
muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam they always
focus on
reason on intelligence on scientific
research
and on intellectual development so
whatever is established through
the scientific process religion would
always support it
on the streets of manchester it's not
just religious beliefs creating doubt
over whether to take the vaccine
no at the moment because only 95 percent
you know
successful no no i'm not why
i because it's very new and i don't know
the side effects
we are scared you know we don't know
which is which and we don't know the
truth about it
there are concerns that misleading
messages could make things worse for a
group that has already been particularly
hard hit by the pandemic
in some cases black asian and other
ethnic minority groups are specifically
being targeted
with anti-vaccination messaging the
fears that target the muslim community
are that somehow the vaccine
contains components that aren't halal or
something else
they're willing to use misinformation
misrepresentation
and outright lies
the british islamic medical association
says muslims in the uk must
treat this purely as a health issue it
is quite important really to
to make sure they will be participating
into that
into the vaccine campaign because this
is actually i think this is health issue
problem it's not it's not faith issue
based on the government's past records
it's likely they'll fail to meet
vaccination targets
experts warn that the idea of vaccine
hesitancy
could be used as a convenient excuse if
that happens
sadia chowdhury sky news